А зараз - «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман
і Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Доброго вечора всім.
Світ збентежений. Ви, ймовірно, також.
Низка загроз нависла з усіх боків.
І це більше, ніж просто песимістична думка.
Війна проти України, і без того жахлива,
таїть у собі ще й небезпеку
наслідків обстрілів найбільшої в Європі АЕС.
А на іншому кінці світу
пекінський правитель погрожує жителям Тайваню
початком регулярних військових навчань.
Військовий конфлікт двох світових держав, США та Китаю,
цілком можливий.
А невизначеність,
яку принесе нам кліматична криза, - і поготів.
Десятиліттями економіка Німеччини розивалася
у дедалі глобалізованішому світі та завдяки йому.
Автомобілі, вироблені за допомогою дешевої енергії з Росії,
які згодом вигідно продавалися в Китаї, -
лише один із прикладів.
Навіть існування такого потужного механізму
як глобалізований бізнес
раптом опинилося під питанням.
Представники зовнішньої та економічної політики
перетворюються на постійних кризових менеджерів.
Далі - Патриція Відемаєр.
За останні кілька років, до коронавірусу, в німецькій економіці
панувала лише одна тенденція -
більше, масивніше, із більшим зростанням.
Цьому посприяли глобалізація та світові зв'язки.
Можна сказати, що благополуччя Німеччини
дуже залежить від глобалізації
і сформувалося саме завдяки їй.
Німеччина має значну вигоду від глобалізації.
І саме тому канцлер Німеччини
міцно тримається за глобалізацію.
І деглобалізація не розглядається як альтернатива.
Якщо говорити простіше, то деглобалізація - це хибний шлях.
Вона нам не допоможе.
Але навіть у галузі економіки стає зрозумілою
необхідність змін, адже рівень залежності зростає.
Сама Німеччина, не маючи багатьох видів сировини,
перевела велику кількість виробництв за кордон.
Через коронавірус та війну виникли серйозні проблеми з поставками.
У майбутньому більшого значення набуде
страхування у разі збоїв поставок.
Тобто буде прагнення створити ще більше
місць зберігання продукції і мати не одного, а двох-трьох виробників
у різних країнах,
які постачатимуть необхідну продукцію.
Але знайти нових країн-партнерів не так просто.
Чи то в Катарі, чи то в Канаді.
І поява нових постачальників також означає,
що все може здорожчати так само, як і газ.
Ми неодмінно потребуватимемо переходу від глобалізації,
яка орієнтувалася передусім на витрати, тобто шукала найдешевшого,
до глобалізації, основним принципом якої є довготривалість.
Але на це, однозначно, потрібні роки.
Крок за кроком. Нам варто почати
всередині країни - з переробки відходів,
запуску потужної циркулярної економіки,
із сировини, яку ми маємо, і водночас
розширювати свої позиції у світі.
Дедалі більше занепокоєння
викликає передусім залежність від Китаю.
Якщо тайванський конфлікт серйозно розшириться,
то наслідки цього відчує
не лише американська економіка,
але і європейська, зокрема й німецька.
Торгівля та інвестиції між США та Китаєм
є центральної віссю,
на якій тримається глобалізація.
Руйнування цих відносин стане великим шоком
для світової економіки, її зростання припиниться.
Також це вдарить по ланцюгах постачання,
у регіоні перервуться поставки морським транспортом,
що матиме довготривалі наслідки для Європи.
На думку неурядової організації «Attac» ідея глобалізації
провалилася вже зараз. За їхніми словами, багато людей
збагатилися, але ще більше - збідніли.
Нам потрібен інший вид глобалізації,
а саме - глобалізація демократії, глобалізація прав людини.
І нам потрібні справедливі торговельні відносини.
Зараз ми маємо глобалізацію,
за якої торговельні відносини визначають
лише великі концерни, сильні країни.
Натомість слабкі країни, зокрема африканські,
не мають шансів на власний розвиток.
Принципи глобалізації минулих років, яка трималася
на кошті бідніших людей і передусім зі шкодою для довкілля,
ймовірно, варто переглянути та оновити.
Багато високопоставлених політиків
зараз перебувають у відпустці.
Здається, наче вони всі хочуть швидко зарядитися енергією
перед надзвичайно напруженими осінню та зимою.
Член комітету із закордонних справ
від партії CDU Норберт Реттген
під'єднується до нас із місця відпустки,
де він продовжує стежити за ситуацією у світі.
Доброго вечора, пане Реттген.
Доброго вечора, пане Зіверс.
Чи не боїтеся Ви того,
що світ потерпає
від декількох криз одночасно?
Тут не можна керуватися страхом.
Ми мусимо усвідомити,
що не можемо впливати на кількість одночасних криз та викликів.
Ми мусимо усвідомити, що з'явилася нова одночасність
із дуже складною будовою.
Зміна клімату, громадське здоров'я, пандемія, Китай, Росія.
Усе одночасно. Ми мусимо це усвідомити. Інакше ніяк.
Куди має рухатися зовнішня політика?
Міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
жорстко критикує Китай.
Також вона виголошує спільну
промову зі своїм турецьким колегою,
а потім публічно сперечається з ним.
Це тактика нового часу?
Нам потрібна не тактика, а стратегія.
Далекоглядна стратегія,
спрямована на попередження криз.
Одна із криз, які можна попередити -
це військовий конфлікт навколо Тайваню.
Заяву Президента Китаю Сі Дзіньпіна
варто сприймати серйозно, адже це обов'язкова програма
його комуністичної партії.
І втілення її в життя призведе до сильної ескалації.
Ми поговоримо про це за мить.
Але куди має рухатися зовнішня політика, зокрема й німецька?
Як-от колишню канцлерку Меркель в Китаї завжди  супроводжувала
економічна делегація для нових інвестиційних можливостей.
А розмови за зачиненими дверима стосувалися прав людини.
У майбутньому такого вже не буде.
Тож правильним шляхом зараз є подання чітких сигналів,
як це робила Ненсі Пелосі в Тайвані?
Наша політика щодо Китаю,
тобто політика щодо експорту промисловості,
наша торговельна політика,
здійснювана за умов ігнорування геостратегічних та безпекових ризиків,
уже в минулому.
Це стосується також і залежності
від російських енергоносіїв,
які Росія використовує як зброю.
Так само і Китай використовуватиме власне зростання як зброю.
Тож ми маємо інтегрувати
в нашу економічну модель геостратегічні та безпекові принципи.
Однієї лише експортної політики недостатньо.
Дії Пелосі - це лише політика символів:
розпалити сварку в час, коли в нас і так достатньо
міжнародної напруги, але немає жодного конструктивного результату.
Найбільший зиск із цього має Сі Дзіньпін,
який зазнає тиску через майбутній з'їзд партії.
Він використовує цю провокацію для розпалення націоналістичних
та мілітаристських настроїв.
Це був дорогий візит, але він не приніс жодної користі.
Нам потрібен не символізм, а серйозна безпекова стратегія.
Ми не можемо вести зовнішню торгівлю без геостратегії.
Ви кажете це як політик, але є ще менеджери.
Наприклад, гендиректор «Volkswagen» каже:
«Майбутнє "Volkswagen" вирішуватиметься
на китайському ринку».
У справі з Росією ми вже маємо
здорожчання енерогоносіїв та нестачу газу.
Якщо ж Китай справді нападе на Тайвань,
чи витримаємо ми ще й санкції проти нього?
Зараз - ні.
Заява гендиректора «Volkswagen» досить сумна.
Він зазначає, що майбутнє фірми залежить
від волі та владних інтересів
великої авторитарної держави.
На мою думку, у прикладі з «Volkswagen» це дійсно так.
Якщо ж ми допустимо, що це стосуватиметься й Німеччини,
вся наша країна та Європа
опиняться у такій саме залежності від Китаю,
як і Volkswagen.
Це стосується не лише Volkswagen, це стосується й Mercedes
та інших автомобільних компаній, і виробників
автомобілів.
Зрештою, це ті галузі економіки, від яких ми всі залежимо.
Можна також додати хімічну та
фармацевтичну промисловість.
З енергетичного сектору та залежності від Росії
ми повинні зробити висновки,
що нам потрібна корекція курсу нашої зовнішньої
торгівлі.
Інакше це призведе до залежності,
яка зробить нас безпорадними у разі конфлікту.
Нам необхідно виправити це
та розробити нову економічну стратегію,
інакше ми перестанемо бути суверенними та
дієздатними.
Якщо до цього ще додасться небезпека пандемії,
це буде надто складно для нашої економіки.
Ми добре жили в умовах попереднього курсі нашої економіки,
те, що ви пропонуєте - забезпечить процвітання в кінці?
Нова геополітична конфліктна ситуація -
це питання добробуту для Німеччини.
Досі нам вдавалося успішно оминати всі ризики.
Зараз нам потрібно відкинути риторику суперечок,
потрібно генерувати нові хвилі росту економіки,
ставати активними і проактивними для забезпечення
нашого добробуту та безпеки.
Ми повинні прокинутися у Німеччині.
Дуже дякую, Норберте Ротген.
Питання про те, як поводитися з політичними
екстремістами,
також постає перед партією AfD.
Як у плані спілкування чи близькості до правителя
у Кремлі,
так і у власних лавах.
Голова Управління захисту конституції, принаймні,
бачить посилення екстремістів в AfD.
Що каже лідер партії Аліса Вайдель?
Сьогодні відбулося "Літнє інтерв'ю ZDF" з очільницею партії,
докладніше Девід Ґебхардт.
У AfD вже кілька місяців існують розбіжності з приводу
її позиції щодо путінської Росії.
У "Літньому інтерв'ю ZDF" лідер партії Вайдель
хоча й засуджує напад на Україну,
але і вбачає в ньому певною мірою співвідповідальність Заходу.
Росіяни завжди ясно давали зрозуміти,
що для них є неприйнятним факт існування ворожої влади
у себе під носом.
Помилка Заходу в тому, що він одразу
не надав Україні нейтрального статусу.
Я вважаю, що неправильно завжди ставити під сумнів,
диференціювати у тих випадках, коли ситуація зрозуміла.
І тут явно простежується воєнна агресія з боку Путіна.
Але останні місяці представники партії AfD
неодноразово виправдовували агресивну війну Путіна,
в деяких випадках поширюючи один в один
кремлівську пропаганду.
Наприклад, що Росія діяла з метою самооборони.
Американці проникли до України.
Це недолужно та неправильно,
росіяни помітили це і тепер вони захищалися.
Існує розкол у відносинах партії щодо ставлення до Росії
і від цього тижня також з Китаєм.
Говорячи про суперечку щодо візитів західних країн
до демократичного Тайваню,
ко-лідер партії Хрупалла вимагав:
«Федеральний уряд має поважати легітимні інтереси
безпеки Китаю».
Нашим завданням не може бути
вираження симпатії до комуністичного, зневажливого до людей
керівництва в Китаї,
це справді нонсенс.
Тенденція до авторитарної, антиліберальної ДНК
екстремістського крила в AfD.
Це одна з причин, через яку вся партія з березня цього року
перебуває під наглядом Управління захисту конституції
за підозри у правоекстремістських намірах.
Суд також вбачав досить багато фактів виявлення
антиконституційних прагнень.
У червні було обрано новий склад очільників партії AfD.
Вперше після реорганізації партії
виступив голова Управління із захисту конституції.
І попереджає в інтерв'ю для ZDF:
Вайдель сперечається, нападає на наше управління.
Це служба внутрішньої розвідки, якої більше ніде не існує.
Управління захисту Конституції зараз використовується
в політичних цілях для паплюження опозиційної партії.
І незалежний суд, слід зазначити, вже заявив,
що Управління захисту конституції
має достатньо доказів.
Партія AfD, новий лідер та старі проблеми.
Ставлення до авторитарних держав і питання,
як поводитися з ультраправим крилом.
Поточна ситуація в Україні, особливо ситуація на
найбільшій в Європі АЕС,
тримає світ у напрузі. Ханно, Вам слово.
Вкотре українська АЕС у Запоріжжі зазнала обстрілу,
і вкотре Росія та Україна
звинувачують одна одну.
Повідомляється, що внаслідок атаки було пошкоджено
сховище відпрацьованого ядерного палива
та датчики для вимірювання рівня радіації.
Електростанцію було обстріляно у п'ятницю.
Оператори вимкнули реактор.
Голова Міжнародного агентства з атомної енергетики
попередив учора про небезпеку ядерної катастрофи.
Експорт зерна з України успішно продовжується.
Ще чотири судна покинули українські порти сьогодні вранці.
Завантажені приблизно 160 000 тонн зерна та
соняшникової олії,
вони прямують до Китаю, Туреччини та Італії.
Через російські атаки весь експорт зерна
з України через її чорноморські порти
в останні місяці був заблокований.
У зв'язку з різким зростанням цін на газ Асоціація
квартиронаймачів Німеччини попереджає,
що в майбутньому мільйони людей не зможуть
сплачувати рахунки за опалення.
Найбільше постраждають ті,
чиї прибутки сягають рівня трохи вищого за суми
державної допомоги,
пояснив очільник Асоціації пан Зібенкоттен газеті Tagesspiegel.
Тому необхідно значно підвищити межу доходів для людей,
які можуть претендувати на житлову допомогу,
вимагав він.
Сьогодні ввечері Сенат США схвалив пакет урядових
заходів
розміром у кілька мільярдів.
Із законами про захист клімату та соціальну політику
важливий проект президента США Байдена
взяв вирішальний рубіж.
Серед іншого він передбачає інвестиції у розмірі
близько 400 мільярдів доларів
для захисту клімату.
Палата Представників ще має дійти згоди,
там демократи мають незначну більшість.
Директор Радіокомпанії Берлін-Бранденбурґ
Патрісія Шлезінґер
відсьогодні залишила свою посаду.
Підґрунтям є звинувачення в кумівстві.
Серед іншого Шлезінґер критикували за укладання
контрактів
на надання консультативних послуг.
61-річна жінка заперечує всі звинувачення.
У четвер Шлезінґер уже подала у відставку з посади
голови ARD.
У зв'язку з можливою хвилею коронавірусу восени
федеральний міністр охорони здоров'я Лаутербах
закликав Постійну комісію з вакцинації
скоригувати свої рекомендації щодо четвертої дози вакцини.
Поки що вона рекомендована лише людям старше 70 років
та деяким групам ризику.
Молодь також хотіла б знати, що їй слід робити.
Тому для кожної вікової групи мають бути «чіткі вказівки»,
сказав Лаутербах в інтерв'ю для «Funke Mediengruppe».
Коли відбувається ескалація насильства
між Ізраїлем та палестинськими екстремістами в Секторі Газу,
настає момент,
коли обидві сторони звертають свою увагу на Єгипет.
Зазвичай це добрий знак.
Бо там посередники
готуються до миру.
Або хоча б до перемир'я.
Так було й цього разу після кількох днів важких боїв.
І, звісно, ​​це означає надію.
Щоб страждання та страх припинилися для обох сторін.
Проте надто довгий досвід воєн у Газі,
на жаль, показує,
що після такого перемир'я починається відлік часу
до нового початку бойових дій.
Андреас Кінаст з репортажем із Тель-Авіва.
Почувши сирени того вечора, Тель-Авів хапається за собак,
мобільні телефони, рушники... і біжить до укриттів,
на годиннику 21 хвилина на сьому,
21 хвилина до початку оголошеного в цей час
припинення вогню.
Кінець дня між новою надією
та новим актом насильства.
Цього разу військовий конфлікт Ізраїлю торкнувся
півдня сектора Газа.
На фото Халеда Мансура - командира угрупування
«Ісламський джихад»
написано «Neutralized» - нейтралізований.
Під час нападів у Рафаху постраждали мирні жителі,
йдеться не тільки про госпіталізованих,
а також й про п’ятьох загиблих, серед них дитина.
Удар був страшним.
Ми в паніці втекли,
жінок та дітей ніби паралізувало від страху.
Я навіть не можу передати, наскільки це було жахливо.
Смуток і гнів панують також на півночі сектора Газа,
у Джабалії загинуло п'ятеро дітей і один дорослий.
У загибелі цих людей Ізраїль звинувачує
бойовиків «Ісламського джихаду»,
які випустили блукаючу ракету.
В той час Ізраїль не проводив жодних операцій в цьому районі.
«Ісламський джихад» вбиває дітей у Газі.
Як доказ Ізраїль оприлюднив це відео,
на якому нібито показано падіння смертоносної ракети.
За оцінками,
третина палестинських ракет падає на Газу.
«Ісламський джихад» продовжував обстрілювати Ізраїль
також цього вечора після 19.00.
Перша спроба припинення вогню провалилася,
наступна має розпочатися о 22.30 за німецьким часом.
«Спіраль насильства» - тільки так можна описати події,
які відбуваються на Близькому Сході.
Це звучить правдоподібно, але не враховується той факт,
що це не конфлікт на автопілоті,
і, що кожна нова ескалація має військові, політичні,
іноді також економічні причини,
і що фундаментальне рішення відсутнє.
З нами на зв'язку Андреас Кінаст з Тель-Авіву.
Чи досягли обидві сторони своїх цілей цього разу?
Ні, не обидві сторони.
Можна сказати, що Ізраїль принаймні досяг
своїх військових цілей у секторі Газа.
Наприклад, вбивство двох лідерів «Ісламського джихаду».
Вчора очільника з півночі, сьогодні з півдня.
Поки що неможливо оцінити, чи вдалося «Ісламському джихаду»
висунути свої вимоги на переговорах з Єгиптом,
серед яких, наприклад, звільнення деяких ув'язнених.
Але навряд чи будь-яка з понад 900 ракет, які угрупування
випустило по Ізраїлю останніми днями, досягла своїх цілей.
Навіть конкуренція з ХАМАСом, другим
за своєю силою угрупуванням,
зрештою стала слабшою, ніж була на початку.
У будь-якому випадку,
у секторі Газа загинуло 40 осіб,
а більшість вже втратила надію на тривалий мир.
Ми продовжуємо розповідати про події на Близькому Сході,
де нічого не працює, але все можливо.
Особливо зараз, коли конфлікт знову потрапляє в заголовки новин,
суперечливість цього регіону важко зрозуміти
і водночас не можна оминати увагою.
Андреас Кінаст і команда ZDF Nahost-Studio
перенесуть нас в унікальне місце у цьому світі,
яке таке вороже до життя і водночас таке вразливе.
Де замираєш від подиву
і водночас починаєш мріяти.
Ще навіть немає 6.00, ще не надто спекотно,
і ще незрозуміло, чи цей ранок принесе те,
на що сподівається команда.
Вони поважають це особливе місце,
нестерпну температуру, нестерпне сонце, а також море,
яке Сігаліт Ландау називає своїм Мертвим морем,
але сьогодні воно трохи ожило.
Для цієї місцевості хвилі - рідкість,
вони дуже заважають мистецтву.
Ви бачите той предмет, маленьку сукню балерини?
Вітер зриває мотузку.
Сьогодні наша місія врятувати її.
Сігаліт повісила сукню балерини в Мертвому морі чотири тижні тому,
а потім просто дозволила воді зробити свою справу.
У цьому морі, вмістом солі понад 30%
не живуть риби чи рослини, лише її мистецтво.
Скульптури Ландау зроблені із солі та часу.
Скульптури, які збереглися, залишаються.
Плаття можна закріпити, але не зберегти.
Скульптури Ландау крихкі,
як море, яке їх створює.
Творіння Ландау мають звернути увагу на те,
що цієї славнозвісної води,
в якій не плавають, а просто тримаються на поверхні,
щомісяця стає все менше,
а її рівень загрозливо падає.
Навіть цієї вузької смужки землі,
на якій ми працюємо,
не було минулі роки.
«Палаюче море» – так називається виставка,
яку Сігаліт Ландау
готує для Музею Ізраїлю в Єрусалимі.
Поціновувачі такого мистецтва платять п'яти-шестизначну суму,
за оригінальні твори Ландау, які завжди солоні, нереальні
і, як і все в Ізраїлі - політичні.
Ми не матимемо нормальності без миру.
Мертве море – це справді можливість.
Воно могло б об'єднати своїх сусідів -
йорданців, палестинців та ізраїльтян.
На користь четвертої сторони, яка потребує порятунку і співпраці,
на благо самого моря.
Особливість цього моря в тому,
що воно таке гаряче, таке їдке, таке мертве.
Особливістю цієї команди є те,
що вона дістає щось живе з Мертвого моря.
Кристалізоване мистецтво, яке повинно дати нам зрозуміти:
Мертве море вмирає, це не вислів, це реальність.
На черзі новини спорту з Ханною.
Розпочнемо ми з Бундесліги.
У першій недільній грі сезону
в поєдинку зійшлися «Штутгарт» та «РБ Лейпциг»,
які зіграли внічию 1:1.
ФК «Кельн» переміг «Шальке 04» з рахунком 3:1.
В Бундеслізі відбулися помітні зміни.
ЗМІ повідомляють,
що повернення національного гравця Тімо Вернера
з «Челсі» в «РБ Лейпциг» неминуче.
Також вже погоджено перехід Антоні Модеста
з ФК «Кельн» в «Боруссія Дортмунд».
На чемпіонаті світу з виїздки в Гернінгу (Данія)
новостворена німецька команда
змушена була задовольнитися «бронзою».
Втретє в історії золота медаль
не дістається Німеччині.
Найкраща вершниця з Німеччини Ізабелль Верт
зайняла 5 місце.
П'єдестал посіла Данія.
«Срібло» дісталося Великобританії.
Це були всі новини неділі.
Що очікувати наступного тижня
розповість Крістіан Кірш
в «heute-journal aus:blick».
Чи залишиться Герхард Шредер членом партії SPD?
Арбітражна комісія відповідного виборчого округу SPD у Ганновері
оголосить своє рішення у понеділок.
17 заяв від різних районних та місцевих асоціацій,
які вимагають виключення ексканцлера
і колишнього лідера партії з SPD.
У вівторок канцлер Шольц
здійснить важливий візит до штаб-квартири
Німецького футбольного союзу у Франкфурті.
Одним із питань є вимога рівної оплати праці
чоловіків та жінок у професійному футболі.
Заклик до рівної оплати праці
набув розголосу після успіху жінок на Чемпіонаті Європи.
Церемонія прощання в Гамбурзі.
У середу збірна Німеччини з футболу вшановуватиме пам'ять
легенди спорту ﻿Уве Зеелера на стадіоні HSV.
Колишній гравець збірної
помер наприкінці липня у віці 85 років.
Канцлер Шольц також братиме участь
у церемонії прощання із Зеелером.
У п'ятницю виповнюється 20 років
з моменту катастрофічної повені на Ельбі.
На початку серпня 2002 року
після сильних опадів струмки, озера та річки вийшли з берегів.
Щонайменше 45 загиблих,
лише в Німеччині збитки перевищили дев'ять мільярдів євро.
Відтоді неодноразово лунали заклики
щодо обмеження будівництва вздовж водойм,
надаючи річкам більше місця для розливу.
Зараз прогноз погоди.
Завтра на півночі місцями очікується щільна хмарність,
в інших частинах буде переважно помірна погода.
Крім того, ще досі надто сухо,
тому виникає високий ризик лісових пожеж.
Найвища температура сягатиме від 21 до 32°C.
Найближчими днями також переважатиме суха
та сонячна погода, від 21 до 34°C.
Від усієї команди
дякуємо Вам за перегляд.
Завтра з Вами в ефірі Марієтта Сломка та Гайнц Вольф.
Гарного вечора.